[Music]
wwdc
just ended and what the heck happened
there
yes that was probably the most
disappointing wwdc because we did not
have
any hardware releases you know that
means i do know what that means we did
not get
a redesigned macbook pro which is very
disappointing
yep so in this video guys we will let
you guys know why
apple did not release the new macbooks
just like everybody was expecting him to
and also when we can realistically
expect those redesigned macbook pros to
come so vadim
why are you holding that thing in your
hand well about a month and a half ago i
made a video claiming
that the redesigned macbook pros are
coming at wwdc
and obviously that did not happen and i
made a bet if it didn't
that i would shave my goatee and i'm so
sad right now
hey at least he didn't deal with miani's
thing i'm not gonna even mention it at
least
so well we're not going to make you guys
wait till the end of a video
let's get this done before we give you
guys the info you guys want to hear
all right lean forward yes do it lean
forward a little bit
hey at least it's not your eyebrows
i can't believe it
how's it look keep like this for the
rest of the video
let's get rid of it well i'm doing it
guys
maybe i'll be more careful next time or
just choosing choosing better timing
yeah
not as supposed to says those macbooks
are probably sitting there ready to be
launched
who knows maybe just like the some of
the other launches that came
out recently where the packaging is was
made
last like last year yeah for the actual
yeah so that's why it's going to be
interesting getting
apple tv oh man enjoy guys
just don't share this on twitter the
deed is done
and now let's get into how all of this
played out so obviously
you weren't the only one that was
talking about this i mean we were pretty
certain about it there were a ton of
other speculators that were certain
about it
leaks were coming out there were filings
that we'll talk about yeah the biggest
one was obviously john prosser
you talked about this he said he
confirmed it
but he also lost eyebrows so we weren't
just relying in our videos on his
data what else happened so it all
started out when a
few analysts were saying that we should
expect it in the second half of 2021
which starts in july
and then based on what happened with the
imac apple revealed it at the
spring-loaded event
and then they only shipped it a month
later so i figured hey
if there if they did that they could do
the same thing with the macbook pros
reveal at wwdc
and ship it out in july so uh it also
kind of matched up with uh details we
had about the
m1x chip actually beginning production
and i kind of like looked at the m1 ship
and how long it took
since the reports of production
beginning and the actual event
and i matched it up almost perfectly
with what could happen at wwdc
and then we had a bunch of other stuff
different analysts saying the same thing
for example we had daniel ives from
wedbush securities claimed that a
redesigned 14 and 16 inch macbook pro
would be coming at wwdc
and then we also had katie huberty from
morgan stanley
saying that at least one new macbook
with apple silicon
is likely at wwdc so we had some
actual legit analysts saying that it's
coming
of course there were also a lot of other
people who were looking at all the facts
all the leaks and they agreed
on this wwc reveal like there was
mcguire wood there was luke miati and
a lot of other people thought this
redesigned macbook pro is coming
and that's not really just guessing
we're looking at all the hardware that
was
leaked and not just leaks where you have
somebody mentioning something and people
that are
reputable but also straight up hardware
filings
and we had the schematics that were
pulled from apple
servers and that was huge a lot of those
leaks
we didn't believe until we saw that and
apple you know
that was real it got pulled down later
like we have the sd card coming back
hdmi hdmi coming back which isn't
changed yeah magsafe coming back so all
of that was
ready and done which is crazy and of
course we had the battery ones right the
filings yeah there's a new filing for a
next-gen
16-inch macbook pro and it showed up in
the regulatory database
right before wwc which usually happens
right before a new product is revealed
and we even had the
battery all the battery details in there
as well so that matches up perfectly for
our new 16-inch yeah
so all this lined up so what happened
why did apple
not release new macbooks at wwdc
and we have a few reasons why we think
that happened
of course one of the biggest culprits is
probably the global chip shortage with
it impacting the auto space
graphics cards all that kind of stuff
now at first we thought that apple was
not going to get impacted because
they have reserves from tsmc and their
chips
but apple did mention that their legacy
or their older nodes
are impacted for example that's why i
think they switched out the apple tv the
new model to the a12
chip instead of the a10x because the
a10x is already old
and the a12 is used in a couple of
different apple products so it makes
sense to just have
that one chip being produced and
manufactured
but of course that's not everything
that's impacting the macbook pros
yeah we had the report come out that
apple is being impacted with their ipad
pro specifically the mini led
version of the ipad pro that's going to
be a shortage at launch
and i know i experienced that i woke up
at 5am to pre-order
and the minute that pre-orders opened
this version i wanted to buy was sold
out instantly i switched to another one
sold out i literally had to choose a
color i didn't want
a capacity i didn't want just to order
one right away so that's
how it was affecting at least my
experience with it and i don't know if
you guys know this or not but the 14
inch mini led macbook pro has been
rumored for a
very long time it's been over a year so
it seems like
apple is only going to be redesigning
and releasing that new model
with the mini led chip so if there are
shortages
it kind of makes sense why they are
delaying the macbook pro so even though
the m1 chip that could be fine they have
capacity for that but just because they
can't make enough
of these macbooks in time that is
probably
the biggest reason why they didn't
announce it at this event and on top of
that we know that every other event
there is
always hardware revealed except for wwdc
where you can have just software only
like we had this year unfortunately so
with that when can we
realistically expect new higher powered
macbooks we have all these great m1
chips but just the m1 we want more
performance
when is that going to come out well the
first thing that could happen
is apple could literally just do a
press release where they put stuff on
their website
they maybe send some ahead of time
there's reviews that pop up
and we don't actually get an event that
could come
you know any time possibly next month or
a couple months from now
apple has done that with imax they've
done that many times with macbooks
so there is a potential but personally i
don't think that
makes a lot of sense yeah it's it's way
too big of a deal
first redesigned macbook pro in years
and it's very important because it's
going to be
a revolutionary product with a crazy
chip the m1x chip is what i think it's
going to be called but it's just going
to be too big of a deal
to not have an apple event yeah this is
apple's
legacy this is history in the making the
m1 is changing the world
windows hardcore fans are switching over
buying macs for the first time
and on top of that mini led new design
ports coming back they can't it's gonna
be great so what's what's the next most
likely
event or what's the next time we can
expect well if it's not now which it
didn't
then the next time is either in october
or november when they have like ipad and
mac based
events so that's a few months from now
which really sucks
that's another option and that's
probably the most likely option
but there is one more thing and i want
to add on like
that could happen you know that's
probably what makes sense fall
yeah but we all know there's lots of
rumors about a new apple tv
gaming version yeah gaming console
something from apple
we have new imacs 30 inch imacs or 28
inch imacs
also coming out iphones iphones two new
ipads
so that's a ton of stuff to pack in in
just a few months so that also
we hope that won't happen and there's
something else i think very likely like
you were saying
what's our third option this is the one
i'm banking on the most so based on what
happened
last year basically apple surprised
everybody and did
three events in three months which they
have
basically never done before so it's a
huge surprise
and that's all based on what happened
with the pandemic and everything with
the lockdown doing the
online only events so there is a chance
that we might get a
completely new surprise event
this summer for these new m1x
yeah and everybody's saying that these
should be coming out somewhere new
macbooks
and that makes a lot of sense because
what do we have in the summer
we have people getting ready for school
students get ready for college apple
does their promotion back to school
promotion
it makes a lot more sense for macbooks
which are you super popular students
from to come out in the summer before
the fall get them in students hands
when they're going back to college um so
personally
i think just like in october we have
november event
apple's one more thing event that was
announced about
eight days before on november 2nd and
november 10th was the actual event
there's a chance if apple wants to get
these in the students hands
early july yeah an announcement coming
out out of the blue
then maybe a week to two weeks later
having another event
with these video events it's a lot
easier people don't have to schedule
flights and get ready and prep all of
that
video shot ahead of time could be done
already it gets live streamed
and that's it so possibly our the third
time when we could see
m1x macbooks redesigned could be in july
and then shipping after that i think
that makes the most sense yeah and in
that case if they actually do have one
of those events
it's likely that the mac mini is gonna
show up at the same time you know if
they have the m1x chip reveal
excuse me we had a lot of leaks about
the mac mini as well yeah with magsafe
coming in
john prosser had the new design leak so
so that is our thoughts on why
the macbook pros were not announced it's
unfortunate they
seem like they stretched out i gotta
give some comments on there yeah some of
the things are sitting there with photos
of dogs and like
usually they fly through stuff really
quick and it seems like they're just
stretched out parts just for the sake of
stretching it out which is
not usually like apples it was
definitely disappointing
especially with ipad os 15 so many
people were waiting on that
we'll make a dedicated video giving you
guys our honest thoughts on that
yeah so you guys let us know what your
thoughts are on this topic you guys can
comment down below of course we have
great videos coming out so if you guys
want to see those
click that subscribe button above and
you can help us reach our goal of a
million subscribers before the end of
the year
that would be awesome we have some great
videos over there this is max and vadim
and we will see you in the next video
[Music]